hey dwight
damn it jim you cannot throw snowballs
in here well it's not a snowball cause
it's only a dusting right
look at that there's a pebble in there
you could have killed me oh don't be
such a baby yeah who's a little girl
now you apologize to me right now
there's something on your nose you
apologize right now no
very well then i challenge you to a
snowball fight
on the first real snow of winter
you got
that sounds awesome
can we all do it no andy it's a snowball
fight it's not fun go get your own thing
reached the voicemail of dwight kurt
schrute please leave
[Music]
i have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but i think it was worth it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
yes take my right okay
okay seriously
okay okay
[Laughter]
oh jim hey hey toby there's this female
uh a stenographer at the courthouse no
it looks exactly like you that's
incredible yeah i know it's on camera
you know what's crazy i can't reconnect
with you right now hold on one second
[Music]
excuse me
hey pickles merry christmas open
immediately
love swiss cheese
damn it dwight
didn't think your affectionate nicknames
would be your undoing did you jim
let that be a lesson to you all
right i'm sorry
i had no idea no it's okay
okay oh my god
oh my god no no no
okay this is it what what is this one go
go oh my god
[Music]
in the end the greatest snowball isn't a
snowball at all
it's fear
merry christmas
oh
okay oh
what is this a
a meatball really
[Laughter]
it's always more fun to mess with dwight
with an audience that was usually pam so
now that she's out i had to find someone
else
turns out that stanley is quite the
comedy fan
but not everything makes him laugh
he has very specific tastes
through a painstaking process of trial
and error i found out what he likes
and it's really weird
jim come on so juvenile
what the you've been meatballed
are you ready for some meatball oh man
this is not very clever jim i know look
for your stapler
[Laughter]
really jim really
very funny
okay
what's a haul
32 meatballs good day
that idiot's been feeding us for a week
we'll never have to buy meatballs again
uh yeah i just got my replacement credit
card
do you want the number oh it's uh four
seven nine three
zero zero three two
three three one three
the security code is
927 okay great thank you very much bye
so dwight did take the bait
use my credit card numbers to send a 200
bouquet of flowers
to my wife
from me
[Laughter]
boom now what about you jim you're a fan
of the game oh no no not really no it's
not for everybody i suppose
that's because i'm more of a player
yeah you bet really jim
i had no idea you played soccer
because you never ever
talk about it
well i do wow i play you could be so
modest somehow maybe we should get back
to work maybe you and charles should
kick the soccer ball around maybe we
will someday maybe you will tonight
after work what do you say it's a great
idea dwight great ideas are just part of
what i bring to the table yeah
i don't try and be anything that i'm not
what do you say jim
i want to play some soccer anybody else
okay i'm gonna join game on okay see you
on the field there bro see you on the
field
yep i used to play soccer in school
from second to fourth grade
i was on the orange team
jim
why would an experienced soccer player
like yourself duck at the very last
moment okay i'm just gonna go get some
ice does that make you feel better huh
i'm i'm sorry fellas oh yeah jim sorry
hey
so jim thought it would be ideal if he
all pitched in
so jim thought it would be ideal if we
all pitched in a 20 for this whole
employee of the month thing
jim said that he thought you were doing
an incredible job last month
jim said that
you seem surprised no no that makes
total sense
hey buddy
so everyone
five minutes ahead of schedule
right on schedule
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome i know
you're all very excited but no matter
who gets this i just want to say that
you guys are all employees of the month
of my house
and the winner is
employee number nine and that is
number nine number nine
jim halbert what what are you kidding oh
no
okay wait
i was not
i did not i'm getting what did not
that was not
i'll come now guys listen this was
anonymous all right there's no way i
could have given it to myself because i
didn't even know who was on here i just
gave it to the employee with the highest
overall score to my tally you just won
back your own parking spot a vacation
day and a nice tidy quarter of a
thousand dollars from all of us well
everybody just stopped for a second
cause obviously i'm not taking any of it
a mistake has been made and we'll figure
it out second of all there was no cash
prize yes
dwight yeah you said in an ideal world
there would be a cash prize isn't that
what you said no dwight i meant yes in a
perfect world someone would get money
but not but
in your perfect world only you get money
yeah that's dumb dude i know all right
what the hell is happening there
hey uh david yes so there was a little
bit of a miscommunication here today
it's been a little wild uh but i am on
it just so i understand you started
employee of the month give it to
yourself
then people complain so you give it to
your wife am i missing something i
really don't know how it happened david
i know how it happened
you